il est de ce marché c'était d'une part
de recréer le marché un marché a dit que
j'ai pas forcément que l'alimentaire
puisque on a ici un savonnier
qu'installer à ligugé qui vient vendre
ses savants sur le marché on a aussi
actuellement du miel est bas au fil du
temps ça va ça va s'étoffer se marier on
a des critères d'évaluation et l'idée
c'est que ça soit collaboratif et que
chacun puisse proposer des idées voilà
et dans le futur on aimerait développer
des temps peut-être plus animation de
partage au moment du marché et les
petits morceaux vous voyez là c'est avec
eux pour regarder c'est aussi fait pour
goûter
y'a pas de soucis on accorde une grande
importance à la qualité des produits
donc
si possible produit le plus
naturellement pro ce possible et le plus
près possible je pétris tout à la main
et façonnent à la main et c'est cuit au
four à bois qu'avec des pins des farines
biologiques et au levain la fermentation
et le vin contrairement à la levure
qu'on retrouve principalement et
boulangeries conventionnel il ya
plusieurs choses c'est que le vin on
termine notre it if sur le blé vous avez
un incident qui est naturellement
présent qui qui empêche la simulation de
certaines vitamines et nutriments qui
sont présents dans le blé donc quand
vous travaillez à la levure de boulanger
vous il n'y a que 50 % de cet acide qui
sont éliminés alors que quand vous
travaillez au levain sur la fermentation
lente il ya 100% de l'acide qui est
éliminé donc ça c'est la première chose
après il ya gustativement parce que le
vin en fait chaque main à ses preuves
aux arômes et comme je dis souvent en
fait si vous prenez la levure de
boulanger c'est une cellules de levure
qu'on a reproduit à l'identique
donc en fait c'est un peu la monoculture
alors que quand vous prenez du levain en
fait c'est un mélange à la fois de
champignons et de bactéries en fait qui
développe du coup leur propre à rome
mais pour moi c'est ce que j'appelle de
la polyculture
donc c'est un peu le même phénomène
qu'en permaculture au camp maraîchage où
on développe une vie aussi en fait une
vie permanente moi je l'entretiens mon
le vin qu'on occupe quasiment tous les
jours et je veux nourrit tous les jours
par contre après surtout ce qui a
hébergé ou sensibilité au gluten il ya
une réalité c'est que les hybridations
suggestives du grain de blé ont favorisé
des gluten en fait qu'ils sont plus
allergènes
c'est pour ça que moi je travaille avec
la ferme de chassagne qui à 50% de l'
essentiel dans son mélange et
enseignants pour cela est un peu plus
moderne parce que les variétés anciennes
sont réputés est sûre il ya une réalité
sont aussi moins allergènes
parce que l on inclut ten qui est moins
allergènes
donc c'est la première chose et puis
donc l'autre avec arnaud chabauty l'idée
était là dès qu'il a semé des variétés
anciennes 100% vérité anciennes de blé
pour aussi faire découvrir aux gens ce
type de pain et le vin aussi permet de
prédire gérer une grande partie des
gluten
toutes ces hybridations là ils ont été
faites pour résister à eau au pétrissage
mécanique pour avoir dépeint qui lève
plus parce qu'on est passé d'une époque
où on voulait des baguettes bien levé
très aérée et donc tout ça en fait c'est
du même logique
et moi je suis dans la logique inverse
c'est à dire que j'ai envie de faire à
la main donc de toutes façons si j'ai
des goûts tonnes entre unis mais trop
fort je vais ça va être plus difficile
pour moi de pétrir donc
donc c'est un autre rapport au temps en
fait c'est un autre rapport au temps et
c'est un autre rapport à la matière
qu'au moment je suis à 100 kg de pain
par semaine l'idée si je veux développer
suffisamment serait de triplés mais
j'aurais gip a priori besoin de plus et
puis moi j'ai un projet à terme de fonds
mobile pour pouvoir faire de la
pédagogie aussi et faire des ateliers et
des festivals aussi de la transmission
d'abord parce que j'habite il jugé ça
c'est la priorité et j'aime bien le fait
de faire travailler des jeux
d acheter des produits de proximité
voilà c'est là c'est les priorités que
je me donne maintenant et balade du
panier du pain et je vais prendre des
légumes et un fromage sans doute voilà
aujourd'hui mais là ça fait oui ça fait
trois fois de suite que je viens donc je
vais essayer de le faire régulièrement
quand je pourrai sur l'agriculture
biologique avec une démarche qui est
vraiment très a fini à l'agroécologie à
savoir essayer de tenir compte de
comment ça fonctionne normalement le
vivant depuis le sol tout ce qui se
passe dans le sol
les plantes et les animaux et considérer
que c'est un tout qui doit rester en
équilibre
donc là c'est un peu difficile c'est ma
première année j'ai pas tout ce qu'il
faut donc c'est pas encore tout à fait
femme ça va venir avec le temps les
cochons sont en plein air je produis sur
la ferme pour l'instant une partie de
mes céréales
à terme toutes mes céréales et puis mes
cochons ils mangent aussi par exemple de
la luzerne
le trèfle des choses comme ça donc ce
sera aussi tout produit sur la ferme et
au quotidien je travaille et non pas
avec un tracteur ou un quad mais avec
des chevaux voilà pour limiter un petit
peu enfin pour ça limite les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre à partir de
pétrole et moi c'est mon plaisir parce
que c'est un peu comme ça que j'ai mis
le pied dans l'agriculture à travers les
shows